[Music]
game three felt like an identity crisis
for vegas not because that's what they
are but because it was far from the
dominant team we've seen all season and
especially in this playoff run becky
hammond knows what they need to do the
players know what they need to do
there's no special pep talk they're just
going out there and getting it done
kevin martin has a story
on sunday the aces will have yet another
chance to close out the series and claim
the franchise's first ever wnba title in
game four against the sun our focus is
going to just be controlling what we can
control and understanding that nothing
comes easy in this league
i don't care who we're playing against i
don't care when we're playing them
nothing comes easy in this league the
aces won games one and two but the sun
responded in a big way in game three
scoring an impressive 105 points the
third most points scored in regulation
of a finals game all time and vegas
knows they can't let that happen again
we have to be more locked in on the
defensive side of the basketball uh and
i think that was our biggest takeaway it
was nothing
blaring or glaring out minus then our
defense like we are a team that plays
out of our defense to then just let
everything just feel out the way it
should there will no doubt be added
pressure on the aces to close out the
series as the last thing vegas wants is
it to come down to a winner take all
game five go out there and just have fun
i think we get so caught up in the rahra
and the mess that we
miss out on the moment that we're in
right now so if we can just capitalize
the moment that we're in and enjoying
that and having fun and playing our way
in our system
i mean it's gonna be a good game between
the two teams regardless kevin martin 8
sports now